hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the amuse
accustomed story
poisonous okay I just went up here for
no reason oh my where the hell did he
come from what in the world holy crap
that is not how I wanted to start this
let's play hard this episode
oh my goofy goober oh my oh it's gonna
crap on me I was not ready for any of
that huh I was like suddenly I jumped
down that I couldn't jump back up oh man
he's just patrolling out there God oh
man this looks important steam room of
sorts what if we got it Oh got red hot
coals maybe I need to do something with
that no oh hell-oh center box fella
that's always handy okay what wow what
the hell
Steve's that pushed me away oh there's
an oil back here cool
that's weird I've never seen anything
like that I heard uh I thought I heard a
moose man out there but I'm not sure
okay
where are you we're already buddy where
are you oh you're right
frigging there god dammit he heard that
oh I'm such an idiot
Oh God these guys are persistent it's
okay no why the perfectly good door that
I had there you to the pluses apart and
come in here I didn't even have a ride
on that is a moose man wait is there a
moose man down here you're done you just
got a bust down the door and go away oh
whoa I'm not in there buddy don't know
what you're doing what I is not in there
you all right you don't seem so good
there friend Oh
I go around and circle back the other
way hopefully won't be back by then
actually I'm not quite sure which way
he's patrolling because originally came
down this man chased me with that back
run is like more persistent than I've
ever seen okay this looks like okay
alright okay I'm fine I'm doing good man
this this this episode that started off
bang if I ever have one get out of the
way okay get out of the way spiderweb
get out of the way anything behind you
nope blocked okay alright I'll hack me
some oil is this custom stories getting
me plenty of oil I mean there's nothing
wrong with brass always nice
ah my god you kidding me what are you
doing
what are you doing what are you doing I
see you are you coming over here don't
do it man huh
don't do it yeah here we go
why good God they're persistent ha man
they're grunts in this one like a real
threat
like it's hard to get away yeah go up
those stairs you dick let's get out of
here
f oh no look at me what F oh how did you
how did you start the chase music I
don't like that at all Oh what are you
doing you're just standing there why
what are you doing you were going up the
stairs oh you're gonna be in that way
walking into the corner good job
what are you doing seems like bugging
out did you stand in there trying to
walk into the corner alright I don't
know how I'm gonna get by him maybe I
just gotta sprint for it
he seems bugged let's get him over here
come here barrel come on help me out
here
block him block him with the barrel lock
him with the barrel what is this what is
this freezer holy hell
lots of Agrippa's aah how where what are
you doing that dude what are you doing
what the doors already gone ah screw it
I'm just going how's it going how's it
going I'm just going to this goat I read
oh no the to really is nitric acid a
glycerol can be combined to a highly
explosive chemical called nitroglycerin
what's important to remember is that
these agrees has to be mentioned and low
temperature else they would explode ah
you still after me
[Applause]
oh okay
mix it a low temperature let me go in
here oh it makes them yay
nothing will be in my way with this true
dat
okay all right oh I was so not ready for
that
where is this place oh man oh man oh man
oh man this custom story man I don't
know if this is like a coincidence but
our things are intentionally set up like
that if it is not a coincidence this
guy's an evil genius if it is going to
this he still makes a good man oh where
am i oh I'm in oh I'm back here okay
those another way up this is good
oh hey that big what that's right oh
yeah what nope no oh no oh no okay I
need to blow something up down here
maybe I'm not sure I don't remember
seeing anything
what Oh a box whose Oh carry the six
levers are controlling the water flow in
the chamber only your pre-installed six
number combination can adjust what I
don't know what a coup there's something
back here
is there something back here oh there's
not something back there in August
that was stupid
look floating rope look at Jane - boo
what's up there hang on a tick what's
this then woo this is why this is
movable why'd you bring it over here
true dat
all yeah okay put that there come on
let me up let me up okay I need that box
come here boxy pink boxes baby yeah you
know boxy you started your own YouTube
channel I remember seeing it a while
back I he was this like she doesn't put
much on it well I haven't checked in
months but there was some sort of I
don't know some I was on my way to do an
ordinary shack on the villages water
system but down here on in these
monsters I succeeded to escape from
their imprisonment but I've been hiding
you for what feel like centuries now and
now I'm running out of food running out
of food what I've noticed is that the
water tastes very bad but I have to
drink it in order to survive if someone
ever reads this please kill these evil
creatures okay that was just like a
little Easter egg boil the oil is huge -
oil is feet now I need to find wherever
the hell oh there he is
haha guy guy right there on my merry way
where was the thing that I was supposed
to blow up what's down here I don't know
okay oh oh okay I should have come down
here
this is this one of us with love I don't
think so what's here there's a whole
nother area that I haven't explored
I got nitroglycerine but I don't
remember what it was for yes I do
no there's nothing to use on this door
this is the beginning door not even a
hand icon I don't know I'll probably
figure out in a bit I'll go down that
other path little on edge this episode a
little bit little on edge things have
been getting to me like a whole time ah
[Music]
what what what what what what what was
going on
rachel is hanging there the water is
riding and will eventually kill her I
need to stop the water flow that does
look like rain so that's like a guy no
to my future self the age is finally
starting to affect my memory so
therefore she was a reminder to
combination that controls a lot of love
first to the day we got married to in
the middle the year we moved into this
house number five
both places to point it the other way
you want the water to go let's do
together the day of my birthday okay I
have all the notes okay okay I'll
remember first two the day we got
married
you mean and in the notes here oh noes
the Diaries over the diary today we got
married the day 13 13 13 13 13 13 13 13
13 13
okay so 13 next two year we moved in
it's 13 see 13 13 13
13 13 13
no that's not it wait no yeah 13 that
would be it 30 years ago so 51 maybe
1351 sounds about right
that's the only thing because it ain't
clean could wear the 1351 1351
fifteen into Gotham 13:51 down what
[Music]
okay anyway 13:51 down ah in the day of
1351 down and then day of birthday 13:51
down six 1351 down and six so one three
five one down and six
what the hell ah don't tell me it it
alt-tab dummy are you kidding me
hopefully it's still recording I don't
know
hahaha what ah come on
are you kidding me my game crashes right
then what why oh that's such bull honky
I can't see anything all right
I'll be back in a second in just a hot
second here I'd actually actually like
okay 14 15 I don't know what happened
that is totally anti-climactic so sorry
about that
boy that's a way to ruin an episode
after my stroke of genius with that but
anyway all right I don't know what the
deal is with that but hopefully I can
get it to I can finagle it into the
right way not sure though nope okay all
right that's pretty much the end of the
episode anyways so thank you all so much
for watching I'll start it again just
before that events happens and hopefully
I need to sort it out to actually work I
don't know like that's the end of the
episode or what or the game or what I
have no idea really so anyway I saw the
nitroglycerine don't know what to do
with it so anyway thank you so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye bye